au milieu du marché de versailles un
drôle de camions a rejoint les stands de
légumes
ici on trouve également des produits
frais mais cuisiner le kitchen et le
premier food truck purement yvelinois le
concept un restaurant mobile dans lequel
en cuisine au milieu des casseroles à
céline sert ses premiers clients
cette biennoise a profité d'un
licenciement pour réaliser son rêve
quitter le secteur de la communication
et vivre de sa passion la cuisine
le concept du foot rock est un moyen
économique de se lancer mais c'est aussi
pour elle toute une aventure
je pense que j'ai envie de voir des gens
différents chaque jour l'idée de
fidéliser des gens un jour par semaine
ou deux jours par semaine avec des
rendez vous réguliers je trouve ça
plutôt sympa l'idée de voilages leur
propose à chaque fois quelque chose de
différent
alors on va pas se voiler la face le
food truck est un phénomène de mode mais
qui a aussi un certain nombre d'
avantage c'est qu'on est nomade et c'est
vrai que bah si un endroit ne fonctionne
pas très bien on peut toujours essayer
d'en trouver un autre même si c'est
beaucoup de travail
faut avoir les autorisations nécessaires
une fois par semaine céline est à
versailles
malgré la pluie le public vient
découvrir sa cuisine française et elle
semble déjà plaire c'est la première
fois que je teste ce type de concept
mais je pense que c'est assez sympa bon
il faudrait qu'il fasse un peu meilleure
mais c'est une alternative à ce qu'on
peut avoir dans d'autres quotidiens du
restaurant d'entreprise ou pour certains
du sandwich
ici on est loin du snack rien que des
produits frais et du fait maison
au menu du jour risotto ou et chine au
miel et orange 11 euros le menu complet
une petite pointe de coriandre et faire
de la gastronomie dans un camion ce
n'est pas toujours évident ça n'a rien à
voir avec une vraie cuisine mais mais ça
a son charme
en dehors du marché de versailles le
vendredi le kitchen pose ses casseroles
sur un centre d'affaires à evry 2 jours
par semaine